la ville d'hier pineau porteuse de kiev
le président volodymyr zelensky annoncé
hier soir un sa libération on retrouve
tout de suite ordinaire de la capitale
notre correspondant du l'hiver craag
gulliver bonjour le président ukrainien
évidemment s'est félicité hier soir de
la libération de la vie quelle est la
situation au moment où l'on se parle
aujourd'hui
au moment où on se parle des opérations
de nettoyage sont en cours dans here pin
cela veut dire que les forces
l'ukrainienne pense qu'il ya encore des
combattants russes dans la ville que il
faut donc éliminer donc des équipes de
combattants ukrainiens sont en train de
procéder à ces opérations et la ville
est encore fermée pour les civils je
vous rappelle la majorité des citoyens
dire pin ont été évacués et la ville est
très substantiellement détruites sinon
depuis le centre ville de kiev on entend
toujours des bruits d'artillerie et on
pense que ce sont les opérations
ukrainienne pour essayer de libérer les
villes voisines dire pin de host aux
mails et butch à d'autres villes
satellites de kiev que les ukrainiens en
promis de libérer des russes -dont dans
les prochains jours les opérations sont
en cours et je pense que les la bataille
à juger des bruits est encore féroce et
sinon quand vous voyez derrière moi qui
aime même si la capitale ukrainienne
respire depuis plusieurs jours qu'on a
l'impression que la taxe russe
l'offensive russe pour essayer de
prendre ou d'entourer la capitale n'est
pas pour tout de suite les ukrainiens ne
pense pas que cette attaque où ces
tentatives dans sa clé a été remise à
jamais et donc les préparatifs et de
défendre kiev elles sont toujours en
cours ici derrière moi vous voyez des
volontaires qui sont en train de
protéger l'un des monuments dans le
centre-ville monument la princesse olga
et on voit des scènes pareilles autour
d'autres statues importante dans le
centre de cannes continue à empiler des
sacs de sable gulliver au moment où l'on
se parle
le président ukrainien cette frêle
s'adresse au parlement suédois cette
fois et le poursuit sa tournée en
distanti ldd parlement internationaux
occidentaux il vient d'évoquer d'alerté
de nouveau sur la situation à marioupol
les attaques russes contre marioupol
sont à un crime contre l'humanité selon
lui on sait que la question sera évoquée
lors d'un coup de fil un coup de
téléphone entre vladimir poutine et
emmanuel macron aujourd'hui
oui emmanuel macron qui veut essayer
d'assurer un couloir humanitaire pour
évacuer les les habitants de marioupol
qui reste dans la ville et on estime
qu'ils sont plus de 150 milles donc
c'est vraiment court beaucoup de monde
qui reste dans cette ville qui est très
substantiellement détruite où on manque
de tout depuis bientôt un mois
maintenant et cette idée de crimes
contre l'humanité a été évoquée hier par
la procureur général d'ukraine rinat
benedicto va en fait en ukraine on parle
très souvent de génocide c'est un mot
qui est très souvent employé je pense
que si on veut se référer à la
définition stricte de génocide il serait
difficile peut-être de prouver que
l'intention était vraiment d'éliminer la
population de marioupol de les tuer mais
en tout cas il y a eu des frappes
complètement indiscriminée sur les zones
civiles dans marioupol et des frappes
sur les colonne de véhicules était
qu'ils étaient en train d'évacuer de
mario paul et mario paul n'est pas la
seule ville concernée par ce genre de
tactique de la part des russes donc on
comprend bien la colère et la détresse
et ce mot génocide et cette idée qu en
fait vladimir poutine aurait des
intentions génocidaires envers le peuple
ukrainien et dont le langage ou coin
employés tous les jours par les
ukrainiens en ce moment merci beaucoup
en direct de kiev donc